buongiorno mi chiamano tiago vesentini e
sono il consigliere rappresentante della
gioventù della croce rossa di milano
oggi voglio raccontarvi una storia la
storia di un viaggio che la croce rossa
ha fatto nel
ce lo ricordiamo quell'anno è l'anno
della pandemia ecco in quell'anno la
croce rossa di milano ha fatto questo
viaggio di 28.000 km 28 mila chilometri
circa
è come immaginare di partire da milano
fare tutto il giro del mondo e tornare
proprio a milano
28 mila chilometri circa il 28 mila
chilometri sono quelli che i nostri
volontari e le nostre volontarie hanno
fatto solo nel 2020 e solo nella città
di milano per portare a casa di chi
fosse in difficoltà sanitaria o
economica i viveri i farmaci e la spesa
in questo viaggio abbiamo incontrato di
tutto giovani anziani famiglie italiane
stranieri chiunque fosse in difficoltà
non importa chi era dall'altra parte del
telefono quello che per noi era davvero
importante quello che per noi è davvero
importante è dare una risposta concreta
a una richiesta d'aiuto
qui potrei veramente raccontarvi di
tante storie me ne vengono però in mente
principalmente due che raccontano per
bene che cosa significa mettersi a
disposizione dell'altro bene è il 9
marzo del
2020 il presidente del consiglio in
italia annuncia il lock down totale
spostamenti consentiti solo per motivi
di lavoro o per motivi sanitari la
nostra quotidianità totalmente stravolta
dalle restrizioni la scuola in didattica
a distanza i comuni e le regioni
tutto chiuso l'italia è entrata in
ma rossa in quel preciso momento
milano ha visto migliaia di persone
prendere i treni gli autobus qualunque
mezzo necessario pur di rientrare nella
propria città pur di tornare nella
propria regione a casa dai propri
familiari
ma in quello stesso momento o comunque
da lì a poco dalle colline dell'umbria
francesca decide di prendere il treno e
tornare indietro a milano quindi viaggia
controcorrente rispetto a tutti gli
altri per francesca non è stato un
momento semplice non è stata una scelta
così banale così scontata una scelta
pensate non totalmente condivisa dalla
famiglia che giustamente era preoccupata
per la situazione pandemica che stavamo
vivendo
francesca era rientrata a casa per il
week end e come era solita fare si era
portata anche la valigia con dentro il
computer del lavoro quindi poteva
tranquillamente dire beh io me ne resto
poi tranquilla e siamo alla mia famiglia
insieme ai miei cani e lavoro dalla
campagna lontana quindi dai rischi di
una città e di una regione la lombardia
tra le più colpite in tutta europa
francesca invece che fa prende e torno a
milano la storia di francesca è una
storia tra tante poteva essere quella di
luigi quella di luca di sarà quella di
tanti altri volontari e quindi francesca
rappresenta un po tutti i volontari e le
volontarie che hanno deciso di esserci
in quel preciso momento storico
passano le settimane
e i telegiornali ci raccontano di quanto
la situazione pandemica sia grave
vediamo medici infermieri personale
sanitario i nostri stessi soccorritori
lavorare giorno e notte per salvare più
vite possibili ma vediamo però anche
altre persone altre persone che con
coraggio e voglio sognare con coraggio
si attengono alle misure restrittive
perché i ragazzi ci vuole coraggio per
restare chiusi in casa coraggio per
rinunciare a uno stipendio coraggio per
tenere a distanza i propri affetti i
propri nonni e proprio e non
coraggio per garantire il bene della
collettività e così dalle case dalle
terrazze dalle cantine dalle soffitte
ovunque vediamo persone che danno sfogo
a una creatività tutta italiana che
tutto il mondo ci invidia
ecco in questo contesto in questa
cornice la croce rossa italiana offre la
possibilità proprio a queste persone
coraggiose di poter aiutare in un altro
modo inizia così l'avventura del
volontariato temporaneo cittadini e
cittadine che scendono in campo per
aiutarci ad aiutare qui veramente potrei
raccontarvi una miriade di storie
avvocati ingegneri architetti
disoccupati insegnanti banchieri
barbieri giovani e meno giovani abbiamo
ricevuto più di 3.000 disponibilità per
tutte queste storie però ve ne voglio
raccontare solo una quella di un ragazzo
felipe un ragazzo brasiliano venuto in
italia per motivi di studio
e qui da poco tempo è poche settimane
ora mettiamoci nei suoi panni
immaginiamo di essere catapultati
dall'altra parte del mondo in un paese
quindi che non è il nostro dove si parla
una lingua che non è la nostra in
un'emergenza sanitaria che mondiale
siamo bloccati perché tanto i voli per
tornare a casa non ci sono poi abbiamo
tutte le preoccupazioni una tra tutte
belle e segna male che faccio con tutti
questi pensieri con tutte queste
riflessioni che cosa vogliamo fare
usciamo veramente di casa
felipe dice di sé si rimbocca le maniche
e ogni giorno si mette a disposizione
all'interno dei supermercati di milano a
raccogliere i viveri per le famiglie in
difficoltà perché vi ho raccontato tutte
queste storie perché sono storie di eroi
no perché sono storie di cittadini dei
cittadini consapevoli che con gratuita
passione si sono messe al servizio della
città della repubblica
al servizio dell'alterità queste sono le
storie importanti le storie di cittadini
consapevoli come disse una volta eri una
il padre della croce rossa tutti possono
in un modo o nell'altro
secondo la sua sfera e secondo le sue
forze contribuire in qualche misura a
questa buona opera ognuno di voi può
aggiungere km a questo bellissimo
viaggio non c'è bisogno di fare il giro
del mondo e non c'è nemmeno bisogno di
entrare in una grande organizzazione
umanitaria
anzi ve lo dico chiaramente non entrate
in croce rossa milano ma dovete essere
presenti ogni giorno nelle vostre scuole
nelle vostre piazze nelle vostre città
nei vostri quartieri siate presenti a
casa vostra aiutate l'anziana della
porta accanto a portare la spesa a bere
il tè a fare due chiacchiere aiutate la
famiglia del piano di sotto con tanti
bambini a fare i compiti a portare il
passeggino su e giù per le scale perché
manca l'ascensore ecco insomma in poche
parole muovete le mani questi grandi
principi di umanità e volontariato sono
universali concreti e tangibili e gli
abbiamo dentro ognuno di noi insomma vi
lascio con un ultimo pensiero
arricchite la vostra vita con linfa di
cittadinanza attiva ciao